I think what people like Elon Musk want
is for you guys all to be living in this
squid game where you all think I don't
care if only one of us will win and 99%
of us will lose I want to fight the
people around me to be in that 1% you
need to change the game you need to
change the game you cannot play a game
where every single year 95% of you lose
96% of you lose 97% of you lose and you
keep hoping to be in that 1% you need to
change the rules of the game and that
means working together that only works
if you guys don't hate each other Elon
Musk is a great example of why
inequality is a danger for you and your
family these guys are going to take the
things that you need they're going to
take your politicians your economists
your media and ultimately your housing
and your food that is what it means you
need to fight
inequality the only way to do that is to
work together that's why these
billionaires want you to hate each other
if you hate each other they'll win if
you work together you can win send this
to your friends send this to your mom
thanks for your help good luck